It's the end of the school year and exams are approaching. When you suddenly realize you forgot to drop that advanced calculus class. You haven't been to a lecture or turned in an assignment all year, and now the final exam is tomorrow and your final grade is going to be a zero. The terror is real, but then you wake up and realize it was just a dream. Hugh! Or maybe your recurring dream is that you can fly, or that you've lost your teeth, or that you found a secret room in your house that somehow you had missed for years.
学年即将结束，考试临近。你突然意识到自己忘了退掉那门高等微积分课。你这一整年都没去上过课，也没交过作业，而明天就是期末考试了，你的最终成绩将是零分。那种恐惧感是真实的，但随后你醒来，意识到那只是一场梦。呼！或者你反复做的梦是你能飞，或者你的牙齿掉了，又或者你在家里发现了一个多年来一直没被发现的秘密房间。
If you're like me, you probably wonder, where do these dreams come from and what, if anything, might they be trying to tell you? Psychologists have also long wondered about the origin and purpose of dreams. Today, we're going to talk about some of their fascinating research and what we know and don't know about why we dream. So why do we dream, and do dreams serve a purpose? What's the relationship between our dreams and what happens in our waking lives? Why are some dreams so common, such as being unprepared for a class or showing up naked in public?
如果你像我一样，你可能也会好奇，这些梦是从哪里来的？如果它们真的想传达什么信息，那会是什么呢？心理学家们也长期以来一直对梦的起源和目的感到好奇。今天，我们将讨论一些引人入胜的研究，以及我们对于“为什么会做梦”这一问题的已知和未知。那么，我们为什么要通过做梦？梦是否有某种目的？我们的梦与清醒生活中的经历之间有什么关系？为什么有些梦如此普遍，比如在考试中毫无准备，或者在公共场合赤身裸体？
Why do some people have particularly vivid and memorable dreams and other people say they never remember dreams at all? Is it possible to influence the content of our dreams or are dreams totally out of our conscious control? Welcome to Speaking of Psychology, the flagship podcast of the American Psychological, Association that examines the links between psychological science and everyday life. I'm Kim Mills. My guest today is Dr. Mark Blagrove, a professor of psychology at Swansea University in Wales. He studies sleep and dreaming and his research interests include sleep and memory consolidation, the relationship between what happens in our waking life and our dream content, and how sharing our dreams with others can build empathy and help our relationships. He is the author with
为什么有些人会做特别生动、令人难忘的梦，而另一些人却说他们根本记不住梦？我们有可能影响梦的内容吗？还是说梦完全超出了我们的意识控制？欢迎收听《心理学谈话》，这是美国心理学会的旗舰播客，旨在探讨心理科学与日常生活之间的联系。我是金·米尔斯。我今天的嘉宾是威尔士斯旺西大学的心理学教授马克·布拉格罗夫博士。他研究睡眠和梦境，研究兴趣包括睡眠与记忆巩固、清醒生活与梦境内容之间的关系，以及与他人分享梦境如何建立同理心并改善人际关系。他是……的作者。
Swansea University Art Professor Julia Lockhart of the book, The Science and Art of Dreaming, published in August. Dr. Blagherove is a fellow of the British Psychological Society and a consulting editor to the APA Journal, Dreaming. Dr. Blagrove, thank you for joining me today. Thank you for having me on the program, Kim. So let's start with the big question. Why do we dream?
斯旺西大学艺术教授朱莉娅·洛克哈特合著的《梦的科学与艺术》一书，该书于八月出版。布拉格罗夫博士是英国心理学会会员，也是美国心理学会《梦》杂志的咨询编辑。布拉格罗夫博士，感谢您今天参加我的节目。谢谢你邀请我参加节目，金。那么，让我们从那个宏大的问题开始：我们为什么要通过做梦？
I know there's not one simple answer to this question, but what are some of the main reasons that scientists have proposed that people dream? Yes, there are indeed many theories for why we dream that have been put forward. One of the oldest ones is that it's to do with our memories being interconnected while we sleep and that we're connecting our recent experiences with past experiences in order to consolidate or make permanent and make interconnected the memories. That's one very current theory, which is also quite longstanding. There's a threat simulation theory that holds that we practice overcoming threats
我知道这个问题没有简单的答案，但科学家们提出的关于人们做梦的主要原因有哪些？是的，关于我们为什么做梦，确实提出了许多理论。其中最古老的理论之一是，这与我们在睡眠时记忆的相互关联有关，我们将近期的经历与过去的经历联系起来，以便巩固记忆，使其永久化并相互关联。这是一个非常主流的理论，也存在了很长时间。还有一个威胁模拟理论，认为我们在梦中练习克服威胁。
our dreams. So, for example, like Kim, you've just said, the threat of being unprepared for an exam, maybe we actually dream of these awful circumstances in order to practice overcoming them in a safe environment. That's another one. There's emotion processing theories as well. There's a fear reduction theory which holds that we dream of our fears, but we dream of them in such a way that the fears then become diminished. And needless to say, there is also the epiphenomenal view, which many scientists would hold and many members of the public would hold, which is that we dream for no purpose at all. It's just the running over of our daydreaming into our sleep. Evolution hasn't got rid of it because it's not really that detrimental to us, and we just have these passing images as we
所以，举个例子，就像金你刚才说的，那种考试毫无准备的威胁，也许我们实际上梦到这些可怕的情况，是为了在安全的环境中练习克服它们。这是另一个理论。还有情绪处理理论。有一种恐惧减轻理论认为，我们梦见自己的恐惧，但我们以一种特定的方式梦见它们，从而使恐惧感减弱。不用说，还有一种“附带现象”观点，许多科学家和公众都持这种观点，即我们做梦根本没有任何目的。这只是我们白日梦在睡眠中的延续。进化并没有淘汰它，因为它对我们并没有太大的危害，我们只是在睡眠时产生了一些转瞬即逝的图像。
sleep and they will disappear unless we wake up and remember them. In my introduction, I described a common dream being unprepared for an exam. Many people have this dream even years after they've graduated from school. And there are other common themes such as flying or being chased or losing your teeth. Do dream researchers have any theories about why these themes appear in so many people's dreams? Yes, there have been studies on typical themes in dreams. That's quite correct. there's a problem with studying it, which is that, say, for example, the dreams of teeth falling out,
除非我们醒来并记住它们，否则它们就会消失。在介绍中，我描述了一个常见的梦，即考试毫无准备。许多人在毕业多年后仍然会做这个梦。还有其他常见的主题，比如飞行、被追赶或掉牙。梦境研究人员对为什么这些主题出现在这么多人的梦中有什么理论吗？是的，确实有关于梦中典型主题的研究。这完全正确。研究它有一个问题，那就是，比如说，关于牙齿脱落的梦，
often the studies are done on these, and they find out have you ever had such a dream? And so some of these dreams may actually occur only a few times in someone's lifetime, but they're actually really quite memorable. But there will indeed be common themes going through dreams. I mean, the one of finding a new room in your house is really quite striking when it happens. and a lot of people will have that a few times in their lifetime as well. And so we do have these themes, especially of threats and lucidity as well, where you realise that you're dreaming, why you're dreaming.
通常研究是这样进行的：他们会问你是否做过这样的梦？所以其中一些梦可能在一个人的一生中只出现过几次，但它们确实非常令人难忘。但梦中确实会有共同的主题。我的意思是，在家里发现一个新房间的梦，当它发生时确实非常引人注目。很多人一生中也会有几次这样的经历。所以我们确实有这些主题，尤其是关于威胁和清醒梦的主题，即你意识到自己在做梦，以及为什么会做梦。
But overall, although we remember these, they are possibly not as common as they appear, and that our more ordinary dreams depict our waking life and depict the circumstances and the concerns and concepts we have. have in our waking life, as well as bringing in these well-known themes as well. Is there some therapeutic meaning to any of this? For example, I mean, I've had that dream about finding secret rooms in my house. And I'm wondering, is that symbolic of something that might be happening in my waking life? Maybe I'm asking you to be a dream analyzer
但总的来说，虽然我们记住了这些梦，但它们可能并不像看起来那么普遍。我们更普通的梦描绘的是我们的清醒生活，描绘了我们在清醒生活中所处的环境、担忧和概念，同时也引入了这些众所周知的主题。这一切有什么治疗意义吗？例如，我做过关于在家里发现秘密房间的梦。我想知道，这是否象征着我清醒生活中可能发生的事情？也许我是在要求你做一个梦境分析师。
at this point, but I'm just wondering what you find out from the research that you do. there is certainly the belief among therapists that there is certainly the belief among many therapists that if you dream of a new room or an extra room or a sofa undiscovered room in your house then that does tie in possibly with the person discovering new things about themselves or wishing to discover things about themselves or something about their past for example or something like that. The main thing, though, for these themes is that, as indeed Freud said, that what we need to do is to, rather than decode things as if this is what this must always mean, is to ask the person for their associations to it. And what would a new house,
在这一点上，我只是想知道你从你的研究中发现了什么。在治疗师中确实有一种信念，即如果你梦见一个新房间、一个额外的房间或家里一个未被发现的房间，那么这可能与一个人发现关于自己的新事物，或者希望发现关于自己的事物，或者关于他们过去的事情有关。然而，对于这些主题，最重要的事情是，正如弗洛伊德所说，我们需要做的不是像解码一样断定这一定意味着什么，而是询问当事人对它的联想。那么，一个新房子，
what would a new room in your house mean to you? Why, why from your waking life are you choosing that particular image to put into the dream? So essentially we interpret our own dreams. We kind of know what the associations are rather than having some universal, like these little dream books that you can buy in the drugstore that tell you if you dream this, it means that. Yes, that's certainly not given any scientific credence to go by those books. Sometimes, I guess, some of the comments in the might give you an inkling of what something could possibly mean. But on the whole, the view is that we ought to serve. for the memory sources of what's from our dreams. Freud called this free association, you think about particular components of the dream and you work out what they're close to in your waking life or recent waking life experiences. The interesting thing though is that although it's the person doing that, saying the associations, it's often very, very difficult for the person to do that on their own. It's actually quite useful to have somebody else ask,
你家里的一个新房间对你意味着什么？为什么在你的清醒生活中，你会选择那个特定的图像放入梦中？所以本质上我们是在解释自己的梦。我们更了解这些联想是什么，而不是像药店里买的那种小梦书，告诉你如果梦见这个，就意味着那个。是的，那些书在科学上肯定没有任何可信度。有时，我想，书中的一些评论可能会让你对某件事的含义有一点暗示。但总的来说，观点是我们应该寻找梦中记忆的来源。弗洛伊德称之为自由联想，你思考梦的特定组成部分，并找出它们与你清醒生活或近期清醒生活经历的联系。但有趣的是，虽然是当事人自己在做这件事，说出联想，但当事人往往很难独自完成。有别人问你，
or what does that mean or what does that remind you of in your recent waking life? Because often we have these enormous blind spots on things. And even the experts, even the therapists, you know, myself, others, we will often completely miss what an association is to a part of our dreams unless somebody who knows us quite well points something out. Why do some people seem to have very vivid dreams and others don't have them or they don't remember them when they wake up? Yes, there has been on the fact that there is a wide difference between people,
或者那意味着什么，或者它让你想起了近期清醒生活中的什么？这其实很有用。因为我们往往在某些事情上有巨大的盲点。即使是专家，即使是治疗师，你知道，我自己，其他人，我们往往会完全忽略梦中某一部分的联想，除非一个非常了解我们的人指出一些事情。为什么有些人似乎做非常生动的梦，而另一些人却不做，或者醒来时不记得？是的，关于这一点，人与人之间存在很大差异，
there's a wide individual difference on what's called dream recall frequency. Surveys seem to find that about a third of people have at least one dream per week. About another third have at least one dream per month. And another third have fewer than one dream per month. so they're less often. And over the last 15 years or so, there's been a lot of work in neuroscience on what distinguishes the high
在所谓的“梦境回忆频率”上存在巨大的个体差异。调查发现，大约三分之一的人每周至少做一个梦。另外三分之一的人每月至少做一个梦。还有三分之一的人每月做梦少于一次。所以他们做梦的频率较低。在过去的15年左右，神经科学领域对区分高频率和低频率梦境回忆者进行了大量研究。其中一个似乎发生的情况是，大脑前部的一个区域和大脑后部的一个区域，在频繁的梦境回忆者中更活跃。这些区域在清醒生活中也是活跃的。但重要的事情似乎是，
from the low dream recall frequency people. And one of the things that seems to happen is that there's areas, an area at the front of the brain and an area at the back of the brain, which are more active in frequent dream recallers. And these areas are also active during waking life. But the important thing seems to be
它们在睡眠中是活跃的，而梦境回忆者在这两个区域有更多的活动。人们还发现，如果大脑后部的区域，有两个叶，一个叫颞叶，一个叫顶叶，它们之间有一个小交汇处，在那个交汇处，如果那个交汇处受到损伤，那么这个人就会完全停止报告梦境。
that they're active during sleep, and the dream recallers have more activity in these two areas. And what has also been found is that if the area at the back of the brain, there's two lobes, one called the temporal lobe, one called the piratal lobe, and there's a little meeting place between them, at that junction, if there is damage to that junction, then the person stops reporting dreams at all.
1997年有一本非常著名的书，由马克·索姆斯撰写，名为《梦的神经心理学》，他在书中回顾了100年的脑损伤案例研究，发现对于在这个特定区域和大脑前部另一个区域受损的人来说，如果它们受损，梦境回忆就会停止。因此，他提出了一个想法，即大脑前部可能有一个区域负责生成梦的内容，
And there's a very famous book in 1997, by Mark Solmes called the Neuropsychology of Dreams, in which he looked back at 100 years of case studies of brain damage and found out for people having damage in this particular area and another area at the front of the brain, if they were damaged, then dream recall would stop. And so he put forward the idea that maybe there's an air at the front of the brain that generates the content of the dream,
并将该信息传递给大脑后部，在那里产生图像。因此，在频繁的梦境回忆者中，这些区域似乎有更多的活动，可能在非常生动的梦境回忆者中也是如此。这很有趣。这与我们大脑处理视觉的方式有任何联系吗？因为梦在很大程度上是视觉化的。那么我们的眼睛在做梦时真的在工作吗？是的。对于许多视力正常的人来说，是的，我们的梦是视觉化的，但大脑后部的区域并不完全是枕叶皮层，那是最后部，是主要的视觉区域。它更多地与一个区域有关，
and it passes that information to the back of the brain, where the imagery occurs. So it seems to be that there's more activity in those areas in frequent dream recallers and possibly in the really vivid dream recallers as well. That's interesting. Is that in any way connected with the way our brains process vision? Because dreams are visual for the most part. So are our eyes actually functioning during our dreams? Yes. For many people who are cited, yes, our dreams. dreams are visual, but the area at the back of the brain is not quite the occipital cortex, which is at the very back, which is the main visual area. It's more to do with an area to do
与视觉意象有关，就在它的前面。事实上，有些人患有一种视觉意象缺失的疾病。所以，例如，你可以问人们，你家前面有多少扇窗户，有些人能够看到他们房子的正面并数出窗格的数量，而有些人就是做不到。而且看起来，那些完全缺乏视觉意象的人也缺乏做梦的能力。因此，这种联系似乎与大脑的意象区域有关，而不是与视觉区域有关，视觉区域更多是视觉输入进来的地方。现在，我倾向于做非常生动的梦，通常涉及
with visual imagery, which is just in the front of that. And in fact, there are some people who have a condition in which they don't have visual imagery. And so, for example, you know, for people who you could ask, you know, how many windows are there at the front of your house, some people will just be able to see the front of their house and count the number of window paints, there are some people who just can't do that. And it does appear that the people who have a complete lack of visual imagery also have a lack of dreaming as well. So it seems to be that the connection is with the imagery areas of the brain rather than the visual areas, which are more where the visual input comes in. Now, I tend to have wildly vivid dreams that often involve
知名人士。例如，去年我梦见我和杰米·李·柯蒂斯在巴西丛林里猎杀吸血鬼。我还梦见我和鲁迪·朱利安尼打网球，他用的是一个坏掉的乒乓球拍。现在，当我在社交媒体上发布这些疯狂的梦时，我的朋友们似乎很喜欢。我想知道，人们从向朋友和家人讲述他们的梦中获得某种心理益处吗？这是一个非常好的问题。在过去的20年左右，有一些关于这个问题的论文，首先，向朋友和家人讲述梦的频率已经得到了评估。评估的原因很简单，或者评估的原因之一是，许多人说这种情况非常罕见。
well-known people. For instance, last year I dreamed I was in the Brazilian jungle hunting for vampires with Jamie Lee Curtis. And I dreamed I was playing tennis with Rudy Giuliani who was using a broken ping pong paddle. Now, my friends seem to enjoy it when I post some of these crazy dreams on social media. And I'm wondering, do people derive some kind of psychological benefit from recounting their dreams to friends and family? Now, that's a very good question. There has been over the last 20 years or so some papers on this, in which, first of all, the frequency of telling dreams to friends and family has been assessed. And that's been assessed for the simple reason, or one of the reasons for assessing that is that many people say that it is very rare for that to
但这种情况其实并不罕见。大约三分之一到一半的人确实会每月一次向别人讲述他们的梦。所以分享梦境其实很常见。已经有几篇论文写到了分享梦境对个人以及他们的友谊和关系的好处，以及由此产生的更亲密的关系。甚至还有关于分享梦境动机的研究，事实上，分享梦境可能是为了娱乐，或者出于想了解更多关于梦的信息，或者因为梦中出现了另一个人。所以他们想分享。
happen. But it really isn't that rare for it to happen. It's about a third of people to about a half of people do recount their dreams once a month to somebody else. So dream sharing is really quite common. And there have been several papers written on the benefits of that to people and to their friendships and relationships of sharing the dreams to other people and the greater closeness that results as a result of that. There's even then been work done on the motivations for sharing dreams and the fact that they can be shared for entertainment or out of a wish to find out more about the dream or because the other person is in the dream. And so they want to share. it for that reason. But whereas all that work had been done for many years, we at Swansea and my work
出于这个原因。但是，虽然所有这些工作已经进行了很多年，但我们在斯旺西，以及我与朱莉娅·洛克哈特（我合作的艺术家）的工作，我们进行了梦境分享小组，因为我们对梦的记忆来源感兴趣。这是原因之一。我们注意到，由于公开分享梦境，我们对分享梦境的人的生活状况有了更多的考虑和理解。因此，我们随后设计了实验，招募了成对的人，一个人会向另一个人讲述他们做过的梦。这是在招募之后。当他们做下一个梦时，他们被告知，互相打电话，见面，讨论这个梦。他们得到了一份讨论梦的协议。在讨论之前，他们填写了一份状态同理心问卷，
with Julia Lockhart, the artist I worked with, we had conducted dream groups with dream sharing because we're interested in the memory sources of dreams. That was one of the reasons. And we noticed that we had a greater consideration and understanding of the life circumstances of the people sharing the dreams with us as a result of public dream sharing. And we then, therefore set up experiments in which pairs of people were recruited, one person would tell a dream to the other one that they had. This was after recruitment. When they had their next dream, they were told, call each other up, meet, discuss the dream. They were given a protocol for the discussion of the dream. And prior to the discussions, they filled out a state empathy questionnaire
评估了这对人中每个人对另一个人有多少同理心。我们发现，在进行了一到四次梦境分享后，听取并讨论梦境的人对梦境分享者的同理心有了显著增加。我们在美国心理学会的《梦》杂志上发表了这一研究的复制版。我们最初发表在《心理学前沿》上。
that assessed how much empathy each person had towards the other person of the pair. And what we found was that after, and what we found was that after one to four dream sharings, there was a significant increase of empathy from the person who was listening to and discussing the dream towards the dream sharer. And we published a replication of that in the APA's journal, Dreaming. We originally published it in Frontiers in,
这是一个非常有趣的发现。我们没有发现做梦并向对方讲述梦境的人对对方的同理心发生变化。因为正如你所料，因为他们专注于自己的梦和自己的生活，他们并没有真正发现更多关于对方的事情。所以他们对对方的同理心没有变化。但我们现在确实已经证明，由于分享梦境，同理心有所增加，并且同理心得到了严格的评估。我们还建议，如果人们轮流进行这种梦境分享，他们很可能会增加彼此的同理心，这确实可以抵消我们目前在西方社会看到的同理心下降。
psychology. And it's a very interesting finding. We didn't find a change in empathy between the person who's had the dream and is telling their dream to the other person, their empathy to the other person. Because as you might expect, because they're concentrating on their own dream and their own life, they are not really finding out more about the other person. So they don't have a change in empathy towards the other person. But we've certainly now shown that there's an increase in in empathy with empathy being rigorously assessed as a result of dream sharing. And what we've also suggest is that if people take it in turns to do that dream sharing, they may very well have increased empathy with each other and that it may indeed counteract decreases in empathy that we
让我问你，我们的一些听众可能听说过睡眠周期以及快速眼动睡眠（REM）和非快速眼动睡眠（non-REM）之间的区别。REM和非REM阶段与梦有什么关系？为什么我们只在睡眠周期的某些部分做梦？是的。1953年，有一个非常著名的实验，它偶然发现夜间有周期性的快速眼动时期。多年来，人们发现每90分钟，
seem to be seeing across Western society at the moment. Let me ask you, some of our listeners may have heard of sleep cycles and the difference between rapid eye movement, a REM sleep and non-REM sleep. How do REM and non-REM stages relate to dreams and why do we dream only during certain portions of the sleep cycle? Yes. In 1953, there was the very famous experiment, which actually by chance found that there was periodic periods of rapid eye movement during the night. and over the years it was found out that every 90 minutes,
就会开始一个快速眼动时期。快速眼动时期在夜间开始时大约持续五分钟，在夜间结束时会长达半小时。你可能在夜间有五个这样的时期。1953年还发现，如果有人从这样的时期被叫醒，他们比从非快速眼动睡眠中被叫醒更有可能报告一个梦。现在，从那时起，我们意识到当时可能存在一种偏见，
a period of rapid eye movement starts. And the periods of rapid eye movement, they're about five minutes near the start of the night, and they get as long as half an hour near the end of the night. And you may have five of these periods during the night. What was also found in 1953 was that if somebody was woken up from such a period, they were more likely to report a dream than if they were woken up from non- Rapid Eye Movement Sleep. Now, since then, we've realised that there may have been a sort of
认为梦发生在快速眼动睡眠中，因此人们忽略了发生在非REM睡眠中的梦。你知道，也许它们很短，也许它们不是那么视觉化，但我们现在意识到梦确实也发生在非快速眼动睡眠中。在睡眠实验室中，大约80%从REM睡眠中醒来的人会报告一个梦，而50%从非REM睡眠中醒来的人会报告一个梦。非REM梦通常较短，如果你按字数衡量的话。随着夜幕降临，你更有可能做一个梦。所以随着你在夜间进入睡眠越深，做梦的可能性就越大。
bias at the time to thinking that dreams occur in rapid eye movement sleep and that therefore people were dismissing the dreams that occurred in non-REM sleep. You know, maybe they were very short, maybe they weren't very visual, but we now realize that dreams do occur in non-rapid eye movement sleep as well. And in the Sleep Lab, about 80% of awakenings from REM sleep result in a dream, and 50% of awakenings from non-REM sleep result in a dream being reported. The non-REM dreams are usually shorter, if you measure it, by number of words. And as the night progresses, you're more likely to have a dream. So as you get more into the sleep across the night, there's a greater chance of the dreams
确实存在。但是，睡眠阶段之间在报告梦境方面似乎存在差异。但我们似乎能够报告夜间大部分时间的梦。不过，我们永远无法确定某人是否会报告一个梦。最近一个有趣的发现是，有一个有趣的最近发现，评估了人们夜间的脑电图，并在夜间反复叫醒人们。最终，通过开发的算法，可以预测这个人醒来时是否会做一个梦。这就是发现，有一个区域，就像我之前说的，在大脑后部附近，如果那个区域非常
occurring. And there is this difference, though, between the sleep stages in the the dreams being reported. But we do seem to be able to report a dream from most parts of the night. We can never quite tell whether somebody is going to report a dream or not, though. And an interesting recent finding was that there was an interesting recent finding which assess people's EEG across the night, woke people up repeatedly. during the night. And it was able to be predicted eventually by an algorithm that was developed whether the person would wake up with a dream or not with a dream. And this was the finding that there's an area, again, like I said earlier on, near the back of the brain, which if that is very
活跃，那么这个人就更有可能报告一个梦。所以我们似乎整晚都在报告梦，但它似乎是断断续续的，而且更有可能发生在快速眼动睡眠中，并且似乎发生在当这个被称为“热区”的区域在大脑后部活跃时。好吧，让我们谈谈你如何研究梦，因为我知道你在实验室工作，人们会进来睡觉，听起来你会整晚叫醒他们。你如何确定什么时候叫醒某人，以及要问他们什么。这难道不会在本质上偏向于正在发生的事情吗？这和你如果在
active, then the person is more likely to report a dream. So we do seem to report dreams throughout the night, but it seems to turn off and on, and it's more likely to occur in rapid eye movement sleep, and it seems to occur when this area, which has been called the hot zone, is active at the back part of the brain. Well, let's talk for a minute about how you study dreams, because I know you work in a lab, and people will come in and sleep, and it sounds like you'll wake them during the course of a night. How do you determine when you're going to wake somebody, what they're going to ask them. And doesn't that somehow bias, in essence, what's happening? It's different from if you were
家里自己的床上睡觉是不同的，也许你那天晚上做了五个梦，你可以在早上告诉别人。是的，那确实是真的。那里确实存在一定程度的偏见。最著名的一个，是在20世纪60年代初发现的，即如果人们在睡眠实验室并进行实验，他们的梦被收集，大约三分之一的梦指的是在睡眠实验室。所以你在睡眠实验室的事实确实会影响梦的内容。现在，它不会影响整个梦，谢天谢地，所以我们得到的不仅仅是关于睡眠实验室的梦。但确实存在所谓的污染。而且，确实存在一种可能性，即如果某人在家里睡觉，梦的自然过程，
just at home in your own bed, sleeping, and maybe you had five dreams that night, and you could tell them in the morning. Yes, that's very true. There is a level of bias there that can happen. The most famous one, and this was discovered in the early 1960s, is that if people are in the sleep lab and undergoing an experiment and their dreams are being collected, about a third of the dreams refer to being in the sleep lab. So the fact that you're in the sleep lab does actually affect the content of the dreams. Now, it doesn't affect the whole dream, thankfully, and so we don't just get dreams which are solely about the sleep lab. But there is that what you could call even contamination going on. And there is the possibility, really, that the natural course of a dream that would have occurred,
正如你刚才所说，在实验室里不会发生。或者在实验室里不会发生到那种程度。但我们确实有一个在实验室里工作的需求问题，因为这是确保，例如，你得到了一个特定长度的REM睡眠梦，比如10分钟的方法。你等待那个人进入快速眼动睡眠，然后你开始计时，然后在10分钟或5分钟后叫醒他们。所以从获得稳健结果的角度来看，我们必须在睡眠实验室，但这是正确的，可能会出现一些偏见。不过请注意一件事，例如，我们做的一些研究，我们希望比较人们的REM梦
as you've just said, if somebody was sleeping at home, doesn't occur in the lab. Or doesn't occur to such an extent in the lab. But we do have an issue really of needing in the lab to, of needing to work in the lab, because that's the way of making sure, for example, that you've got a REM sleep dream of a particular length, let's say 10 minutes. You wait for the person to go into rapid eye movement sleep and then you start the stopwatch going and then wake them, say 10 minutes later or five minutes later. So from the point of view of getting the robust results, we have to be in the sleep lab, but that is correct, there can be some bias occurring. Note though one thing, which is that, for example, some of the studies we do, we wish to compare people's REM dreams
和他们的非REM梦。当然，那个人不知道他们做的是REM梦还是非REM梦。所以我们仍然可以做研究，向他们展示他们的梦，并获得对梦的评分，例如，它持续了多久，或者其中有多少情绪，或者实际上对于我们做的一些研究，梦指的是他们日记中记录的多久以前的事情？我们发现，REM和非REM梦在梦的记忆来源上存在时间过程差异。在这种情况下，偏见较少，我想，因为你在看某人的REM和非REM梦，只有实验者才知道哪个梦是哪个。
with their non-REM dreams. Of course, the person doesn't know whether they've had a REM dream or a non-REM dream. So we can still do studies where we show them their dream and we get ratings of the dream, for example, such as of how long it was or how much emotion there is in it, or indeed for some of the studies we've done, how far away, how far back in their diaries they've been keeping, do the, does the dream refer to? And what we find is that there's a time course difference between REM and non-REM dreams on the memory sources for the dream. And in that instance, there's less of a bias, I guess, because you're looking at someone's REM and non-REM dreams, and it's only the experimenters that would know which dream is which.
REM和非REM梦之间有定性差异吗？是的，有定性差异。非REM梦较短。它们可能情绪较少，角色较少，场景较少。关于这一点存在争议，一场辩论正在进行，因为如果你控制梦的字数长度，那么短的快速眼动睡眠梦与长的非快速眼动睡眠梦非常相似。所以一个理论说，实际上REM和非REM梦的区别仅在于它们持续了多久。
Are there qualitative differences in REM and non-REM dreams? Yes, there are qualitative differences. The non-REM dreams are shorter. They may have fewer emotions, fewer characters, fewer scenes. And there is a dispute, a debate goes on about that, Because if you control for the length of the dream in words, then short rapid eye movement sleep dreams are very similar to long, non-rapid eye movement dreams. And so one theory says that actually the REM and non-REM dreams only differ in terms of how long they are.
存在那种差异。它们实际上没有任何定性差异。它们实际上没有任何定性差异。当你接近夜间结束时，非REM梦开始看起来更像REM梦。它们开始变长，开始变得更离奇，角色更多。所以所有这些多种因素都在夜间影响着梦。让我们谈谈噩梦。心理学家认为它们有什么目的？
There's that difference. And they don't actually have any qualitative difference. they don't really have any qualitative difference. As you get nearer to the end of the night, the non-REM dreams start to look more like REM dreams. They start to get longer, they start to get more bizarre and with more characters. And so there are all of these multitude of factors coming in that affect the dreams across the night. Let's talk about nightmares. What purpose do psychologists think they serve?
是的，关于噩梦有很多想法。我的意思是，有医学观点，临床心理学观点，即如果噩梦让一个人非常痛苦，那么它们可能需要治疗。有一种方法可以做到这一点，意象排练疗法，即当事人在白天想象他们的噩梦，并改变其中的部分。这减少了他们做的噩梦数量。那种对待噩梦的方法会将它们视为一种睡眠障碍，你知道，就像呼吸暂停是一种睡眠障碍或失眠一样。所以它会从我们如何减少一个人发生的噩梦数量的角度来看待它。
Yes, there's a whole range of thoughts about nightmares. I mean, there is the medical view, which is, and clinical psychology view, which is that nightmares are something that possibly need treating if the person is really distressed by them. There's a method for doing that, imagery rehearsal therapy in which the person imagines their nightmare and images their nightmare during the day with changed parts to it. And that decreases the number of of nightmares that they have. And that type of approach to nightmares would see them as a disorder of sleep, you know, much as apnea as a disorder of sleep or insomnia, say. And so it would see it in terms of how do we reduce the number of nightmares that are occurring to a person.
然后是关于噩梦的理论。甚至有一个理论说，在噩梦中，噩梦对你有益，因为它们是你练习对自己最严重威胁的地方，它可能对个人不舒服，但像疼痛一样，它实际上是有用的。所以有一个关于噩梦的进化理论，认为它们是有益的。另一个理论说，梦通常有功能，你知道，可能与记忆有关，这是一种可能性，或者情绪处理，当我们做噩梦时，这对大脑来说在夜间太多了，所以噩梦是一个迹象，表明做梦的功能已经失败。所以有所有这些理论。最近有一个有趣的
There are then theories of nightmares. There's one even that says that in nightmares, nightmares are beneficial to you because they are the place where you practice the most severe threats to yourself, and it may be uncomfortable to the individual, but like pain, it's actually useful. So there is an evolutionary theory of nightmares, which says that they are beneficial. Another theory says that dreams in general have functions, you know, possibly to do with memory and is one possibility or emotion processing, and that when we have a nightmare, it's been too much for the mind during the night, and so the nightmare is a sign that the function of dreaming has failed. So there are all those theories. There's been an interesting recent
论文关于那些做噩梦更频繁的人，在清醒时看到负面照片时的反应较少。其中一种可能性是，频繁的噩梦使人们适应了令人讨厌、可怕的图像，这样当我们在清醒时，它们就不会那么困扰我们。所以甚至有那种支持功能的观点，认为噩梦在那个角度有功能。你如何研究噩梦？试图在睡眠实验室诱发噩梦似乎是不道德的。那么你如何看待噩梦？是的，那是真的。
paper about the people who have more frequent nightmares react less to negative photographs that they're shown when they are awake. And one possibility there is that the frequent nightmares attune people to nasty, horrible images so that we're less bothered by them when we're awake. So there's even that pro-function, view that nightmares have a function in that point of view. How do you study nightmares? It seems like it wouldn't be ethical to try to induce nightmares in a sleep lab. So how do you look at nightmares? Yes, that's true.
导致某人做噩梦几乎肯定是不道德的。是的，通常做的是自然主义实验。所以，例如，1989年，加利福尼亚发生了地震。居住在加利福尼亚的人们因此受到了研究。结果发现，加利福尼亚的人们做的噩梦比亚利桑那州的人多得多。他们不仅仅是做关于地震的噩梦，
It would almost certainly be unethical to actually cause someone to have nightmares. Yes, what's usually done is naturalistic experiments. So there was, for example, in 1989, an earthquake in California. And people living in California were studied as a result of that. And it was found that the people in California were having many more nightmares than were people in Arizona. And they weren't just having nightmares about earthquakes. but they were having nightmares in general.
他们还在做一般的噩梦。所以你可以找那些经历过创伤事件的人，研究由此导致的噩梦增加。另一种可能性是，与其谈论像那样极端的群体，不如说我们做的一些研究涉及招募大量人群，比如200人，询问他们做噩梦的频率，并将其与他们的焦虑、抑郁和压力水平相关联。然后你发现焦虑、压力、抑郁和做噩梦之间存在中度相关性。所以你可以在那里进行自然主义的研究，找出为什么有些人
And so what you can do is get people who've been through a traumatic incident and study the increase in nightmares that results. Another possibility is, rather than talking about extreme populations like that, is that some of the studies that we've done have involved getting a large sample of people, say 200 people, asking them how often they have nightmares and correlating that with their levels of anxiety and depression and stress. And what you find then is moderate correlations between anxiety, stress, depression, and having nightmares. So you can do studies in a naturalistic sense there that find out why some
比其他人更容易做噩梦。我们最近做了一项关于感觉处理敏感性这一非常、非常有趣的人格特质的工作，有些人是高度敏感的人，而另一些人不是，有一个非常有趣的27项量表来衡量这一点。伊莱恩·阿伦是它的设计者。我们发现，如果你有压力，作为一个高度敏感的人会使你更容易做噩梦。但如果你感觉处理敏感性较低，并且有压力，它不会导致
people have nightmares more than others. We've recently done work on a very, very interesting personality trait of sensory processing sensitivity, that some people are highly sensitive persons and other people aren't, and there's a very interesting 27 items scale for measuring that. Elaine Aaron was the divisor of that. And what we found is that being a highly sensitive person predisposes you to have nightmares if you're stressed. But if you are low on sensory processing sensitivity and you have stress, it doesn't cause
他们做噩梦。这是一个混杂因素。这是感觉处理敏感性之间的相互作用。有些人很容易被刺激淹没，他们对声音感到惊吓，他们可能是更深思熟虑的哲学型人。高度敏感的人，如果被置于压力情境中，更有可能因此而以噩梦作为反应。做梦是人类独有的吗？还是其他动物也会做梦？关于动物做什么，这很有趣。因为我们经常，许多人，包括我自己，看着我的猫，你可以看到猫和狗在移动，好像它们在试图抓住什么东西。
nightmares for them. It's a confound. It's an interaction between sensory processing sensitivity. Some people are easily overwhelmed by stimuli and they jump at sounds and they're possibly more thoughtful philosophical people. People who are highly sensitive persons, if they're put into a stressful situation, are more likely to respond with nightmares as a result. Is dreaming unique to humans or do other animals dream as well? Now that is interesting about what do animals do? Because we've often, many people and myself, including with my cats, you can see cats and dogs moving as if they're trying to catch something.
它们在睡眠中做有节奏的动作或其他类型的动作。所以有那种间接证据表明非人类动物可能正在做梦，它们在夜间对此做出反应。这非常、非常合理。毕竟，这些动物很可能具有一定程度的，甚至可以说是类似于我们的白日梦，或者类似于我们的意象。所以可能它会渗入它们的睡眠中，也会做梦。在关于做梦的儿童发展文献中，存在一场关于儿童是否做像成年人那样的梦的辩论。
They do rhythmic movements or other type of movements during their sleep. So there is that type of circumstantial evidence that non-human animals might be having dreams that they're reacting to during the night. that is very, very plausible. After all, these animals quite possibly have a level of, possibly even daydreaming, you could say similar to us or imagery going on similar to us. And so possibly it would seep over into their sleep to have dreams as well. There is a debate within child development literature on dreaming as to whether children have dreams which are quite like adults.
你知道，比如有很多角色的离奇梦。或者儿童，其他发现是儿童做非常、非常原始的梦。在生命的最初几年，并没有真正包含其他角色，或者他们可能只是梦见宠物或动物或身体状态。从这个角度来看，也就是做梦的认知和神经认知观点，人类发展了做梦的技能。我们必须一直发展它，直到我们十几岁的时候。现在，从这个角度来看，如果神经认知学派的人是正确的，
you know, bizarre dreams with lots of characters, for example. Or do children, other findings are that children have very, very rudimentary dreams. For the first few years of life, not really with other characters in, or they may just dream about pets or animals or bodily states. And from that point of view, which is the cognitive and neurocognitive view of dreaming, humans develop the skill of dreaming. And we have to develop it up until the time. when we're in our teams. Now, from that point of view, if the neuro-cognitive people are correct,
加州大学圣克鲁兹分校的比尔·多姆霍夫是其中最著名的人之一，那么你真的不会指望动物会有比原始梦更多的东西，因为根据他，以及神经认知观点，即使是年幼的儿童也有非常、非常原始的梦。所以我们可以怀疑动物会有很多那样的东西。所以你提到观察你的猫在睡觉时，它们可能会移动腿，好像它们在梦中追逐什么东西。我想知道梦游的问题。我的意思是，我们知道人们会那样做。梦游与做梦有什么关系？
Bill Dolmhoff at University of California, Santa Cruz is one of the most famous ones for that, then you wouldn't really expect animals to have very much more than rudimentary dreams, because according to him, and then you're a cognitive point of view, even young children have very, very rudimentary dreams. So we can doubt that animals would have very much going on like that. So you mentioned watching your cats when they're sleeping and they may move their legs as if they may you are chasing something in their dream. I'm wondering about the issue of sleepwalking. I mean, we know people do that. How does sleepwalking relate to dreaming?
是的。快速眼动睡眠的一个有趣之处在于，除了大脑在REM睡眠期间非常活跃，眼睛有这些周期性的爆发之外，在睡眠期间，我们的肌肉张力几乎完全消失了。所以我们的肺还在工作，我们的心脏还在工作，但几乎没有其他东西在工作。因此，人们发现人们在非快速眼动睡眠期间说梦话和梦游，因为那是执行这些动作所需的肌肉在工作的时间。通常的观点是，梦游的人并没有梦见他们在走，在做什么。这是通常的观点。而说梦话的通常观点同样是，这个人并没有做一个梦，
Yes. One of the interesting things about rapid eye movement sleep is that as well as the brain being very active during REM sleep and the eyes having these periodic bursts. during the sleep is that our muscle tone is almost completely gone. So our lungs are still working and our hearts are still working but very little else. And so what's been found is that people sleep talk and sleepwalk during non-rapid eye movement sleep because that's the time when the muscles that are needed to do that are working. The usual view is that the people who are sleepwalk are not dreaming of what they are walking, of what they are doing. That's the usual view there. And the usual view of sleep talking is similarly that the person is not having a dream,
这与说话有关。所有这一切的一个例外是所谓的REM行为障碍，这确实非常罕见，但在那种情况下，所谓的失张力，即在快速眼动睡眠期间发生的缺乏肌肉张力，消失了。所以这个人可以把梦演出来，有时甚至可以把非常暴力的梦演出来。这有时会引起当局和刑事当局的注意，因为有时患有REM行为障碍的人可能会实施暴力行为。但这种障碍确实非常罕见，而梦游和说梦话是相当常见的非REM状况。我想谈谈清醒梦，也就是人们意识到自己在做梦的梦。
which is related to the talking. The one exception to all of this is what's called REM behaviour disorder, which is really quite rare, but in that the, what's called atonia, the lack of muscle tone that occurs during rapid eye movement sleep, he's got rid of. And so the person can act out dreams and can actually sometimes act out quite violent dreams. And this sometimes gets to the notice of the authorities and criminal authorities because there is the possibility sometimes of violent acts being committed by some thoughty with REM behaviour disorder. But that disorder is really quite rare, whereas sleepwalking and sleep talking are quite common non-REM conditions. I want to talk a little bit about lucid dreaming, which is the dreams where people are aware
这与梦话有关。所有这些情况的一个例外是所谓的快速眼动睡眠行为障碍，它确实非常罕见。在这种情况下，快速眼动睡眠期间出现的所谓肌张力缺失（即肌肉张力丧失）消失了。因此，人可以把梦境演出来，有时甚至会演出相当暴力的梦境。这种情况有时会引起当局和刑事部门的注意，因为患有快速眼动睡眠行为障碍的人有时可能会实施暴力行为。但这种障碍确实非常罕见，而梦游和梦话是相当常见的非快速眼动睡眠状况。我想谈谈清醒梦，也就是人们意识到自己在做梦的梦。
that they're dreaming and that they might even be able to influence what happens in the dream to a certain extent. What can you tell our audience about lucid dreaming? How does it happen? How common is it? Yes, lucid dream is dreaming is really quite rare in that. about half the population in Europe and North America have had a lucid dream once in their lifetime. And about 20% of the population have a lucid dream about once every month. And so they're really quite, they're relatively rare. In the sleep lab, what's been found is it's about two to three percent of rapid eye movement sleep dreams are lucid dreams, where somebody actually knows their dreaming and the dream
他们意识到自己在做梦，甚至在一定程度上能够影响梦境的发展。关于清醒梦，您能告诉我们的听众些什么吗？它是如何发生的？有多普遍？是的，清醒梦其实非常罕见。在欧洲和北美，大约有一半的人一生中经历过一次清醒梦。大约20%的人每个月会经历一次。所以它们确实相对罕见。在睡眠实验室中发现，大约2%到3%的快速眼动睡眠梦是清醒梦，即做梦者实际上知道自己在做梦，而梦境
continues. And so as well as knowing that it's a dream, they could if they chose to affect the content of the dream, that can affect the plot or introduce characters to the dream or in a recent one that I had to decide to fly. And so that can happen as well. So they are really quite, they really are quite rare, but very interesting when they do happen. Because they happen in rapid eye movement sleep. There is a view that the brain needs to be really quite active in order to have them. They don't really seem to occur in non-rapid eye movement sleep. And one of the main methods for inducing lucid dreams is to have the person wake up a couple of hours earlier than they would normally wake. Get up, walk around, do things for an hour or two, and then go back to sleep for a
还在继续。除了知道这是个梦之外，如果他们愿意，还可以影响梦的内容，比如改变情节、引入新角色，或者像我最近做的一个梦那样，决定飞行。这些都是可能发生的。所以它们确实非常罕见，但发生时非常有趣。因为它们发生在快速眼动睡眠期，有一种观点认为大脑需要非常活跃才能产生清醒梦。它们似乎不会在非快速眼动睡眠期发生。诱导清醒梦的主要方法之一是让受试者比平时早醒几个小时。起床，走动，做些事情一两个小时，然后再回去睡个
nap. And because they've then delayed the second part of their sleep or the later part of their sleep, the brain is really quite active then. And so what's found is that this what's called wake back to bed method is very good for inducing lucid dreams. So the first thing is we seem to think it's to do with a very active brain causing you to be lucid. The second thing is that some people may just sometimes notice that something is weird or incongruous in a dream and say, are, am I awake or am I dreaming? And indeed, there's even a method developed around that, which is a reality checking method where people check reality in the day. They continually ask themselves, am I awake or am I dreaming? And hopefully it can carry over into their dreams. So a combination
回笼觉。因为他们推迟了睡眠的后半部分，此时大脑非常活跃。研究发现，这种所谓的“醒后重睡法”对于诱导清醒梦非常有效。所以首先，我们认为这与大脑高度活跃导致清醒有关。其次，有些人可能偶尔会注意到梦中有些奇怪或不协调的地方，从而问自己：“我是醒着还是在做梦？”事实上，甚至有一种围绕此开发的方法，即现实检验法，人们在白天进行现实检查。他们不断问自己：“我是醒着还是在做梦？”希望这种习惯能带入梦中。所以，综合
of all those reasons cause people to have lucid dreams, there is a personality measure of internal locus of control, which we found is related to lucid dreams, internal locus of control people believe that they're in charge of their own life. They also believe that other people are quite in charge of their own lives as well, or ought to be, and people who are high on internal locus of control tend to have more lucid dreams. So it's as if that personality feature creeps over into their dreams and causes them to be aware of dreaming and even wanting to control the dream. Is it something that you can teach yourself, though, over time? Yes, it can be taught if people are very interested in lucid dreams.
所有这些原因，人们才会做清醒梦。有一种人格测量指标叫“内控点”，我们发现它与清醒梦有关。内控点高的人相信自己能掌控自己的生活。他们也认为其他人同样能够掌控自己的生活，或者应该如此。内控点高的人往往会做更多的清醒梦。这就像是这种人格特征延伸到了梦中，使他们意识到自己在做梦，甚至想要控制梦境。不过，这可以通过后天学习掌握吗？是的，如果人们对清醒梦非常感兴趣，是可以学会的。
Indeed, what can sometimes happen is people can hear about lucid dreams for the first time so they know they exist, and that can cause people to start having a lucid dream because they know that they exist. Also, if people fall asleep wanting to have a lucid dream, that can help them to have one. there's the wait-back-to-bed method that I've mentioned earlier on, and there's now technological measures, either in the sleep lab or you can buy these, in which, for example, there'll be a mask that's put on your face, and that detects whether your eyes are moving during sleep, and when the eyes are moving, it flashes red lights at you, and the red lights cause the dream to change, either with red objects come in, or a red hue goes towards the entire environment, and the
事实上，有时人们第一次听说清醒梦，知道它们的存在，这本身就可能导致他们开始做清醒梦，因为他们知道这种现象存在。此外，如果人们带着想做清醒梦的愿望入睡，这也有助于实现。我之前提到的“醒后重睡法”是一种，现在还有一些技术手段，无论是在睡眠实验室还是市面上买到的设备，例如，有一种戴在脸上的面罩，可以检测睡眠时眼睛是否在转动。当眼睛转动时，它会向你闪烁红光，红光会导致梦境改变，要么出现红色物体，要么整个环境笼罩在红色调中，
person may then realize that they're dreaming and can then question, oh, I am dreaming and they know they're having a lucid dream and the dream is, the dream carries on as a lucid dream. Hmm. Now, there are some things that we do in life that I think we just don't tend to do in dreams. For example, I don't think people do math in their dreams. What are some of the things that we do in our waking lives that we just don't ever dream about? Yes, that is interesting. there's a very famous paper by Ernest Hartman, who was a very major psychiatrist and dream researcher. And he wrote a paper in 1995 called We Do Not Dream of the Three R's. So we don't dream of reading, writing and arithmetic.
那个人可能就会意识到自己在做梦，从而质疑：“哦，我在做梦。”他们知道自己正在经历清醒梦，而梦境会以清醒梦的形式继续下去。嗯。现在，生活中有些事情我觉得我们往往不会在梦里做。例如，我不认为人们会在梦里做数学题。我们在清醒生活中做的一些事情，有哪些是我们从来不会梦到的？是的，这很有趣。欧内斯特·哈特曼（Ernest Hartman）有一篇非常著名的论文，他是一位非常重要的精神病学家和梦境研究员。他在1995年写了一篇名为《我们不做关于“3R”的梦》的论文。也就是说，我们不会梦到阅读、写作和算术。
And even though we spend a lot of the time doing those things in our waking life, they may just not be interesting enough to occur in our dreams, unless, of course, there's some reason to have it there in the dream. So despite the fact that we spend so much time doing these things, they don't show up in our dreams very much. Now, the interesting thing there is, though, that that was a sort of observational study that Ernest Hartman did. If you actually want to do an experimental study
尽管我们在清醒生活中花了很多时间做这些事，但它们可能不够有趣，不足以出现在梦中，除非梦中有什么理由需要它们出现。所以，尽管我们花了很多时间做这些事，它们在梦中出现的频率并不高。不过，有趣的是，那只是欧内斯特·哈特曼做的一项观察性研究。如果你真的想做一个实验研究，
to show that what's emotional to you in waking life is more likely to come into your dreams, that's really quite intricate to do that. And so the way that that's done is that the way that various teams have done that is to get people to keep a diary. And in the diary they record what's happened to them during the day and the levels of emotion of what happens to them during the day. Then they record any dreams that they have.
来证明清醒生活中对你而言有情绪波动的事情更容易进入梦境，这其实非常复杂。实现这一目标的方法是，各个研究团队让受试者写日记。在日记中，他们记录白天发生的事情以及这些事情带来的情绪水平。然后，他们记录下所做的任何梦。
And what they do next is they're asked to compare the diaries to their dreams. and they asked, okay, what in the diary ended up in your dream? So the person is not allowed to say, ah, this came from my dream, I know where that's from, but they hadn't put it in the diary. This is very strictly and rigorously controlled. So you can only use the things that were in your diary. And what's found then is that the items in diaries
接下来的步骤是，要求他们将日记与梦境进行对比。他们被问到：“好的，日记里的什么内容最终出现在了你的梦里？”受试者不允许说：“啊，这个来自我的梦，我知道它来自哪里”，但如果他们之前没把这件事写进日记里，就不算数。这是非常严格和严谨的控制。所以你只能使用日记中记录的内容。研究发现，
that go into dreams tend to be more emotional than the items in diaries that don't go into dreams, to the dream. And so that's, in a way, the evidence that we tend to dream of what's emotional to us. We did a follow-up study to that at Swansea because those dreams in those studies were dreams that people reported at home. What we did in the Swansea Sleep Lab was we got people to keep a diary for 10 days. We then got them to sleep in the sleep lab and we woke them from REM sleep and from non-REM sleep. And we then got them to compare their dreams to their diaries.
进入梦境的日记内容往往比那些没有进入梦境的内容更具情绪色彩。这在某种程度上证明了我们倾向于梦到对我们有情绪意义的事情。我们在斯旺西（Swansea）做了一项后续研究，因为那些研究中的梦是人们在家中报告的。我们在斯旺西睡眠实验室所做的是，让受试者写了10天的日记。然后让他们在实验室睡觉，并在快速眼动睡眠和非快速眼动睡眠期间唤醒他们。接着让他们将梦境与日记进行对比。
And what we found was that for REM dreams and non-REM dreams, if an item, items that were incorporated into dreams were significantly more emotional than items that were not incorporated into dreams. But if you had positive emotions, they were just as likely to go into your dreams as negative emotions. So as long as something is emotional, it's got a good chance of getting into your dreams, whether it's a positive emotion or a negative emotion. So that's in a way shows the explanation for Ernest Hartman's finding that we don't tend to dream of these mundane activities from our waking life. Although I imagine if I were a mathematician, I would probably dream about math, but I'm not.
我们发现，无论是快速眼动睡眠梦还是非快速眼动睡眠梦，被纳入梦境的内容在情绪上都显著高于未被纳入梦境的内容。但如果是积极情绪，它们进入梦境的可能性与消极情绪一样大。所以只要某件事带有情绪色彩，它就有很大机会进入你的梦境，无论是积极情绪还是消极情绪。这在某种程度上解释了欧内斯特·哈特曼的发现，即我们往往不会梦到清醒生活中那些平凡的活动。虽然我想如果我是数学家，我可能会梦到数学，但我不是。
Yes, you may very well. If something's really meaningful to your life, I mean chess players, for example, may very well be indeed that, that something that is then not their mundane part of life, but could be really important to them, that they could then be dreaming of that indeed, yes. So I have to ask you about this kind of longstanding myth. I think I've heard it as a kid, that you can never dream that you've died because then you would die in your sleep. And as someone who has had such a dream in which I died, I know it's not true. Where do these ideas come from?
是的，你很可能会。如果某件事对你的生活非常有意义，比如国际象棋选手，他们很可能确实会梦到这些。这不再是他们生活中平凡的部分，而是对他们非常重要的事情，他们确实可能会梦到这些。所以我必须问你关于这个长期存在的迷思。我想我小时候听说过，你永远不会梦到自己死亡，因为那样你会在睡梦中死去。作为一个做过这种梦并梦到自己死亡的人，我知道这不是真的。这些想法是从哪里来的？
Yes, indeed. that there is a common belief, a folk belief that you can't dream of dying in your dream and that if you do so, you may actually physically die. It's a very interesting belief. Obviously, scientifically, it'd be very difficult to test for it because you may have various dead people. I'm sorry to be so gruesome about it, you know, you'd end up with various dead people and you'd have no way of knowing whether they had actually dreamt of dying just before they died. So notwithstanding the fact it's very difficult to test this scientifically.
是的，确实如此。有一种普遍的民间信仰，认为你不能在梦中梦到死亡，如果你梦到了，你可能真的会生理性死亡。这是一个非常有趣的信仰。显然，从科学上讲，这很难验证，因为你可能会有各种死者。很抱歉说得这么可怕，你知道，你最终会有各种死者，而你无法知道他们在死前是否真的梦到了死亡。所以，尽管在科学上很难验证这一点，
I do wonder whether there are long-standing folk beliefs. There may be even be famous stories even that were developed of or horror films that were developed on the idea that if something that shocking occurred in your sleep, then it may actually cause you injury during your sleep. You know, the nightmare on Elm Street type of thing that if they dream of Freddie attacking them and scratching and stabbing their body, they wake up and it has actually physically happened to them. So the idea that what could physically happen to you in your sleep can affect you physically is quite a long-standing one, and I guess you could even extrapolate it to
我确实想知道是否存在长期存在的民间信仰。甚至可能有一些著名的故事，或者是基于这种想法创作的恐怖电影，即如果睡眠中发生了如此令人震惊的事情，它可能会在睡眠中对你造成伤害。你知道，像《猛鬼街》那种类型，如果他们梦到弗莱迪攻击他们，抓挠并刺伤他们的身体，他们醒来时发现这真的在身体上发生了。所以，睡眠中发生的事情可能会在生理上影响你的想法由来已久，我想你甚至可以将其推演到
dying. I mean, it may very well be that it's, whereas we can imagine most things or vast numbers of things as daydreams, and so you can imagine, we can imagine vast, number of things as dreams as well, that it may not be possible to have a dream about, it may not be possible to have a dream about dying because it's such an awful thing to think about. Well, let's close with a question that I wanted to ask you, which is regarding dream deprivation. We know that sleep deprivation, can be quite harmful to people's health. What happens when people are deprived of the ability to dream?
死亡。我的意思是，虽然我们可以把大多数事情或绝大多数事情想象成白日梦，所以我们可以把绝大多数事情想象成梦，但可能无法梦到死亡，因为这太可怕了。好吧，让我们以一个我想问你的问题结束，关于梦境剥夺。我们知道睡眠剥夺对人们的健康非常有害。当人们被剥夺做梦的能力时会发生什么？
Yes, when rap-in-eye movement sleep and its association with dreaming was found in the 1950s and early 1960s, there did start to be the theory that you needed to dream, and therefore that if people were deprived of the ability to dream, then somehow the dreams would crop up elsewhere in psychosis or some type of fears or hallucinations, that type of thing. Now, the reason why that's a little bit doubtful is because we do know that very many people just have very, very few dreams at all. It's about 6% of people report absolutely never dreaming. And they could be woken in the lab and some of them do in,
是的，当快速眼动睡眠及其与梦境的联系在20世纪50年代和60年代初被发现时，确实开始出现一种理论，认为你需要做梦，因此如果人们被剥夺了做梦的能力，那么梦境会以某种方式在精神病、某种恐惧或幻觉中以其他形式出现。现在，这个理论之所以有点令人怀疑，是因为我们确实知道很多人几乎根本不做梦。大约6%的人报告说完全不做梦。他们在实验室里被唤醒时，有些人确实在
have dreams, but we know that a very, you know, some people just seem to have no dreams at all and we can't quite see any deficit for them, as a result of them not having the dreams. Now, it is known that if people are deprived of rapid eye movement sleep, a very interesting phenomenon occurs which is called REM rebound, which means that when they next go back to sleep, They don't wait 90 minutes for the next rapid eye movement sleep period. They try to get back into a REM period as quickly as possible. They try to get back into a REM period as quickly as possible. And so it's as if people have an urge to have rapid eye movement sleep.
做梦，但我们知道，确实有些人似乎根本不做梦，而且我们无法看出他们因为不做梦而有任何缺陷。现在，已知的是，如果人们被剥夺了快速眼动睡眠，会发生一种非常有趣的现象，称为“REM反弹”，这意味着当他们下次入睡时，他们不会等待90分钟进入下一个快速眼动睡眠期。他们会尽可能快地尝试回到REM阶段。他们会尽可能快地尝试回到REM阶段。所以这就像人们有一种对快速眼动睡眠的渴望。
And there may very well be biological reasons for that. You know, we may be setting biochemicals in that state after the long trials of the day. There may be something to do with memory console. for rapid eye movement sleep. So it may very well be important, and that's why we have rapid eye movement sleep rebound. But whether the people are needing the REM sleep in order to have dreams, and they're having the rebound for that purpose,
这背后很可能有生物学原因。你知道，在经历了一天的漫长考验后，我们可能正在那个状态下调节生化物质。这可能与记忆巩固有关。所以快速眼动睡眠可能确实很重要，这就是为什么我们会有快速眼动睡眠反弹。但是，人们是否需要REM睡眠来做梦，并且为了这个目的而产生反弹，
is doubted, I think, by most people, because there seems to be enough biological reason to have your rapid eye movement sleep, let alone the fact that at the same time as the REM periods are occurred. you may very well be having dreams as well. So it's very difficult to deprive people of dreaming unless you actually physiologically deprive them of rapid eye movement sleep as well.
大多数人对此表示怀疑，因为似乎有足够的生物学理由来保证你的快速眼动睡眠，更不用说在REM阶段发生的同时，你很可能也在做梦。所以，除非你在生理上剥夺了人们的快速眼动睡眠，否则很难剥夺人们做梦。
So it would be very difficult to work out whether or not, in fact, it's the inability to have these images during the night that is causing them any problem. Now, of course, if the people who believe that dreams have a function, are correct, then there may indeed be some deficit to not having your dreams. It may indeed be that, you know, you're not fully, one possibility is that we need to turn dreaming on and off during the night in order to finish with a burst of consciousness our processing that's going on during the night. So it may very well be that we do need our dreams for that final little bit of processing
因此，很难确定是否真的是因为夜间无法产生这些图像而导致了任何问题。当然，如果那些认为梦境具有某种功能的人是正确的，那么不做梦确实可能会带来一些缺陷。可能确实是，你知道，你没有完全……一种可能性是，我们需要在夜间开启和关闭梦境，以便用一阵意识来完成夜间正在进行的加工处理。所以我们可能确实需要梦境来进行最后一点加工
that's occurring. But whether or not there's actually a detriment that would be seen if people didn't have their dreams, there's not really any evidence for that yet. And so for those listeners who tend not to dream or remember their dreams, you're okay. You're certainly okay. And Ernest Hartman developed this scale, which is similar in a way to some of sensory processing sensitivity, which he called his bounderiness questionnaire. and there are thick-boundary people who are sort of no-nonsense folks.
正在发生的事情。但是，如果人们不做梦是否真的会产生损害，目前还没有任何证据。所以对于那些往往不做梦或记不住梦的听众，你们没问题。你们当然没问题。欧内斯特·哈特曼开发了这个量表，在某种程度上类似于某些感官处理敏感度，他称之为“边界问卷”。有“厚边界”的人，他们是那种脚踏实地的人。
They like to have stories with a beginning, a middle and an end. They see the world in quite black and white terms. And then there are what he called the thin boundary, more artistic types, who are a bit more creative, possibly, a bit more emotionally labile, possibly. And he pointed out that the thick-boundary people, they may have fewer dreams, but we need the thick boundary people and we need the thin boundary people. We need the infrequent dreamers who may see themselves as more in touch with the world and with the physical world.
他们喜欢有开头、中间和结尾的故事。他们以相当黑白分明的方式看待世界。然后是所谓的“薄边界”类型，更具艺术气质，可能更具创造力，可能情绪也更不稳定。他指出，厚边界的人可能做的梦较少，但我们需要厚边界的人，也需要薄边界的人。我们需要那些不常做梦的人，他们可能认为自己与世界和物质世界联系更紧密。
And we need the more spontaneous dreamers as well. So it's a sign of, in a way, diversity that we need all the different folks, the high and low dream recallers as well. Well, Dr. Blago, I want to thank you for joining me today. This has been absolutely fascinating. I could go on for another hour, I'm sure. Great. Thank you.
我们也需要更自发的梦者。所以，这在某种程度上是多样性的标志，我们需要所有不同的人，包括高频和低频的梦境回忆者。好的，布拉戈博士，我要感谢您今天加入我的节目。这绝对令人着迷。我相信我可以再聊一个小时。太棒了。谢谢。
It's been very nice speaking to you as well, Kim. Thank you. You can find previous episodes of Speaking of Psychology on our website at speaking of psychology.org or on Apple, Spotify, YouTube, or wherever you get your favorite podcasts. And please leave us a review. If you have comments or ideas for future podcasts, you can email us at speaking of psychology at APA.org. Speaking of psychology is produced.
和你交谈也非常愉快，金。谢谢。您可以在我们的网站 speakingofpsychology.org 或在 Apple、Spotify、YouTube 或您获取喜爱的播客的任何地方找到《心理学谈话》的往期节目。请给我们留下评论。如果您对未来的播客有评论或想法，可以发送电子邮件至 speakingofpsychology@apa.org。《心理学谈话》由
by Lee Weinerman. Our sound editor is Chris Kondayan. Thank you for listening. For the American Psychological Association, I'm Kim Mills. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
李·韦纳曼（Lee Weinerman）制作。我们的声音编辑是克里斯·孔达扬（Chris Kondayan）。感谢您的收听。我是美国心理学会的金·米尔斯（Kim Mills）。本集目前还没有评论。点击转录稿中的任何句子即可发表评论。